[Applauso]
avete idea di quante persone ogni anno
muoiono per malattie cardiache nel 2016
uno studio ha dimostrato che circa 10
milioni di persone muoiono per patologie
cardiovascolari
un dato allarmante è il risultato del
2018 circa 17,5 milioni di persone sono
decedute per questa malattia è questo
che oggi mi spinge ad approfondire
questa branca della medicina
ma partiamo un po dall'inizio avevo 5
anni ero un piccolo no netto che correva
per casa
non che ora se è più alto insomma e ero
molto legato al mio nonno e ogni volta
che andavo a far visita a lui trovava la
sua stanza piena di medici
lui aveva una malattia degenerativa e
questo mi spinse a dire cavolo
meglio essere un medico anch'io poi nel
2013 successe qualcosa
mia cugina abbia un malore tutti mi
dicevano a un buco al cuore e dicevo un
buco al cuore ma cos'è non capivo nulla
inizia a documentarmi online
praticamente mi ero fidanzato
ufficialmente con dottor google iniziato
a studiare questa malattia e ora so che
è un caffè in ps o con precisione e una
mancata coesione del setto interatriale
quindi con conseguente miscuglio di
sangue ossigenato e non ossigenato
inoltre presentava un ulteriore difetto
il cosiddetto ritorno venuta anomalo
in pratica la vena polmonare anziché
entrare in altro sinistro entrava in
altro destro ci avete capito qualcosa
fidatevi che non ci capivo nulla neanche
io da piccolo
inizia a studiare questo mondo inizia a
studiare queste tecniche alla tecnica
chirurgica la tecnica mininvasiva e mi
appassiona in maniera particolare ad una
tecnica l'angioplastica mi incuriosì
perché malgrado sia la tecnica del
futuro presenta numerosi vantaggi
uno di questi è appunto e la cosiddetta
di sezione l'infiammazione tutti i
paroloni che da piccolo mi sembravano
completamente estranei
quindi inizia a studiare mi posti una
domanda perché se questa metodica il
futuro della medicina ha ancora un muro
che la blocca così mi butta via libri
inizia a studiare prima online e poi
verso 14 15 anni con premio primo bel
manuale di cardiologia ma era
completamente un qualcosa di estraneo a
me inizia a buttare giù qualche schema
inizia a lavorare la mia scrivania era
piena di disegni di appunti non ci
capivo nulla
mia madre e la mia cosa intelligenze
all'oscuro di tutto iniziavano a
prendermi seriamente per pazzo
e forse un po lo ero anche inizia a
studiare il tutto e iniziò a prendere
vita appunto il cosiddetto stand
pericardico autoespandibile questo non
si va da un altro interrogativo che mi
sono posto se queste protesi durante le
angioplastiche provocano questi tutti
questi disturbi al paziente perché non
costruire con un materiale più morbido
così inizia a studiare e necessitare
anche un tessuto che il tessuto
pericardico all'epoca sapevo soltanto
che il pericardio venisse e fosse una
membrana carico che va il cuore non era
mai venuto in mente di capire il perché
venisse usato anche medicina però capite
bene che un cilindro di tessuto ho messo
così in un vaso serve a ben poco
quindi devo pure legarlo a qualcosa è
iniziato a studiare quelle che erano
delle leghe metalliche appunto il
meeting assemblato il tutto ero così
contento ho finito tutto quanto tutto mi
sembrava tutto più chiaro
ma ecco che arriva iniziarono ad
arrivare i problemi non avevo valutato
lo spessore della protesi per dirla
tutta una protesi troppo spessa avrebbe
ucciso il paziente per un medico non è
che sia il massimo non credete allora mi
ributto ai suoi libri come lincoln
proprio come nei film ma ero lì studiavo
ero anche un po giù di morale perché non
credeva quello che stavo facendo
alla fine dopo aver chiesto anche aiuto
alla mia prof che non ci aveva capito
assolutamente nulla
inizia a leggermi un bel manuale di
cardiologia e lì trovai le mie risposte
allora sembra il tutto e poi iniziò un
qualcosa che la mia fase stalking del
momento devo ricercare appunto due
centri
ai quali mandare il progetto e ne
seleziona i due uno in svizzera è uno in
italia
scrissi poche righe sulla mia mail
allega il mio progetto che all'epoca era
soltanto questo disegnino è una
paginetta e poi niente lamanda e di in
maniera molto incoscienza
il giorno seguente mentre mi svegliavo
veramente mi investivo per andare a
scuola
ricevetti una piccola e mail vidi quindi
il logo di gmail sul telefono di sì
cavolo che cos'è questa mail l'apri eder
al centro svizzero
immaginate la mia felicità inizia a dire
oddio è bellissimo qualcuno mi ha
risposto ma nel leggere le mail
ci rimasi malissimo mi dicevano che ero
un ragazzino non ci potevo capire nulla
che quindi non era un medico vero mi
sentivo un po deluso un po deluso da me
stesso un po deluso da quello che il
mondo della medicina della ricerca ma
poi il giorno seguente successe qualcosa
ricevetti un'altra mail dal centro
italiano ed era il dottor fausto
castriota all'epoca responsabile della
cardiologia interventistica di cotignola
in provincia di ravenna
lui mi scrisse che voleva incontrarmi
subito dopo due giorni io ero
felicissimo saltavo correvo come come un
pazzo non sembra come stesso arriva ora
però il momento più difficile
dovevo dire tutto i miei perché comunque
erano degnare di tutto
allora arriva il caso la prima fu mia
madre mi racconta il tutto e le rimase
così quasi a dire ma mi stai prendendo
in giro non potevo neanche dirle pesce
d'aprile perché eravamo a dicembre
quindi il tutto sembrava sarebbe
sembrato un po strano poi ho parlato con
mio padre e non ci pensò due volte a
dirmi partiamo in realtà quando siam
partiti non abbiamo detto a nessuno che
andavamo a studia in questo centro a
ravenna dicevamo che avevamo a farsi un
giro proprio perché comunque non ci
credevano tanto a questa cosa ma poi
arrivate di qualcosa cambiò e appunto il
12 dicembre 2015
partimmo da taranto per cotignola
arrivamo lieviti dottor castriota e non
mi sembrava fatto un medico era una
persona diversa dalle altre mi aspettavo
una figura seria professionale invece si
presentò così piacere fausto piacere
fausto piacere fausto ed era molto umano
quindi fu questo a spingermi diciamo
ancora di più a studiare questo mondo
della cardiologia ii disse i genitori
una cosa andatevene in giro a ravenna
perché tanto giuseppe rimane come tutto
il giorno invece indossare una divisa
fate conto che indossa unix s2000 ed una
m era enorme e mi disse entriamo in sala
operatoria sei pronto gli oli mi bloccai
il suo dio e se dovessi svenire tutti
quei macchinari sembravano dei razzi
spaziali un qualcosa che comunque era al
di fuori dalla mia portata mi piacque
davvero tanto pensate che fosse finito
tutto qua e invece no torno a casa che a
malincuore ovviamente e ricevetti una
chiamata era lui il presidente del
gruppo voleva farmi di un'altra
settimana
io ero contentissimo e dopo circa un
mese risaliva iniziai appunto a
frequenti lui mi ricordo che quel giorno
doveva effettuare una procedura chiamata
tavi ovvero la sostituzione della
valvola aortica per via percutanea
arriviamo nel blocco operatorio di
cardiochirurgia intra facemmo questa
procedura
una volta usciti lui entrò in un'altra
sala operatoria in cui si svolgevano un
intervento a cuore aperto
immaginate la mia faccia dietro una
finestrella così avevo comunque 15 anni
ero un bambino vedevo tutto quel sangue
usciva luni vide e mi porto dentro
una volta lì mi chiese ti piace tutto
questo e dissi che non mi sarei più
mosso da quel posto avevo trovato lavoro
del mio futuro appunto
il cardiochirurgo da allora mi buttai
all'interno della ricerca inizia a
studiare gli stent la loro struttura
fate conto che uno stent tradizionale
presenta delle leghe metalliche queste
leghe metalliche però hanno dei problemi
quindi possono andare a lacerare il vaso
ad infiammarlo e quindi il paziente può
aver necessità di un intervento
chirurgico al più presto insomma è
questo comunque non deve essere il punto
fondamentale della medicina bisogna
sempre spingersi oltre comunque per
cercare nuove metodiche un'altra cosa
importante è appunto è quella
dell'angioplastica e l'impianto dello
stento con palloncino cosa succede una
volta impiantato lo stent è gonfiato
appunto con il palloncino le maglie
metalliche potrebbero andare a finire
all'interno della zona cava
scolare quindi lacerarla paziente se non
arriva in tempo in una cardiochirurgia
morirebbe allora a quello che ho fatto
io è stato in sostanza modificare tutta
la struttura non modificato la struttura
dalla parte esterna che poggia
direttamente sul vaso è una struttura in
pericardio bovino che sarà che viene
immerso in un farmaco immunosoppressore
per ritardare appunto la risposta inter
ma anti infiammatorie
la risposta infiammatoria e invece la
parte interna è composta da delle
piccole cellette di nanotecnologie che
servono appunto a praticare l'auto
espansione della protesi quindi
immaginate come una protesi cardiaca sia
totalmente più come dire biocompatibile
per il paziente
insomma questa è una valvola cardiaca
costruita in pericardio enit in oro e
una lega completamente molle comunque
resistente all'interno del vaso ma
riesce a dare grandissime proprietà al
tutto
forse vi starete chiedendo come ho fatto
beh melo melo sta tenendo ancora anch'io
e ho 19 anni
e allora c'è un mondo sulla cardiologia
sia on line che i suoi libri di testo
immaginate che all'inizio era una
paginetta questo testo più che una
pagina era un disegnino e paura invece
un progetto di 40 pagine quel lavoro di
laboratorio lavoro teorico ed è stato
davvero bellissimo poter fare tutto nel
2018 mentre online nei siti un concorso
il concorso regionali scienziati era
promosso dall unione europea e iniziare
a chiedere un po anche al momento raimi
professori se potevo farcela allora mi
hanno detto
parlo ma del progetto allora io mi misi
ii scrisse compilati tutti i moduli
manda il progetto
immaginate di nuovo questa scena dopo un
mese alla fine della selezione ero dal
medico di famiglia
ero seduto lì e ricevetti ramirez dal
concorso
ricordo soltanto due parole siamo lieti
lo ricordo più niente perché
sinceramente non sono neanche continuato
a leggere la mail torna a casa
non sono più entrato neanche nello
studio del medico perché sono uscito
direttamente per correre a casa
sono nato lì ho raccontato tutto a mio
padre a mia madre che lavorano
rispettivamente all ilva di taranto è
un'altra perché mia madre casalinga
invece è quindi nessuno in ambito
scientifico ed erano davvero orgogliosi
di me e inizierà una piangere preparare
le valigie e parti per milano candeli e
vinse il concorso dei giovani scienziati
per unione europea ma
[Applauso]
credete che i riconoscimenti sono finiti
qui dopo questo è arrivato anche l'expo
science europe a gdynia in polonia
l'expo science international quindi
olimpieri dei progetti scientifici di
instabul in cui mi sono aggiudicato la
medaglia d'oro il premio 100 eccellenze
italiane al palazzo montecitorio
il premio regione puglia premio misteri
un festival e infine lo scorso marzo
sono stato nominato alfiere della
repubblica dal presidente della
repubblica in persona
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma adesso torniamo un po indietro
crederete magari che la mia vita è
sempre stata perfetta e non ci siano mai
stati degli ostacoli dei problemi ma in
realtà no avevo 16 anni
già da piccolo avevo dei sintomi alzavo
male magari i medici pensavano che mi
stessi diciamo inventando il tutto sui
dolori che avevo che magari gli stessi
immedesimando nei sintomi di mia cugina
ma non era così
mi credevano un po pazzo dicevano di
andare dallo psicologo ma c'era qualcosa
che non andava e lo sapevo anch'io a 16
anni mentre la scuola è un valore
importante mi portarono in ospedale e mi
fecero una tac con contrasto all'addome
avevo un infarto intestinale in corso in
quanto un grosso vaso del dl dell'aorta
addominale era strozzato appunto da un
legamento
la sindrome si chiama sindrome di un bar
e una sindrome è molto rara infatti non
avevo mai sentito
non avevo mai sentito il suo nome non
avevo mai letto nei libri di testo
in pratica un grosso vaso dell'arte
dell'aorta addominale ovvero il tripode
celiaco viene strozzato da quello che
detto il legamento arcuato ovvero una
parte della cupola diaframmatica sono
stato operato dopo circa due settimane a
bari in quell'ospedale che conoscevo la
perfezione non sapevo se piangere se
magari sentirmi al sicuro lì dentro non
sapevo neanche io se ti quasi un mese e
mezzo in ospedale ed è stato quasi come
un inferno
però ci fu il dottor castriota che vivi
se a mio agio assisti all'intervento e
quindi mi piace sentire davvero in buone
mani
poi grazie agli amici e alla mia
famiglia e ai medici che mi volevano
bene sono riuscito a buttarmi alle
spalle questo momento ad avere quella
forza che non credevo neanche io di
avere ora sto bene ma non benissimo
infilatevi ora vi faccio ridere un po lo
scorso anno ero su instagram a guardavo
le storie del mio amico io noi siamo
molto legati l'amico d'infanzia e diceva
questa sera si fa alla ted
idv mattia ma se tu vai là ted detto ci
sarei voluto andare anch'io alla ed ho
fatto io mi risponde perplesso fa 6 ma
la the della discoteca di taranto io a e
invece oggi sono qui al vero ted ed è un
onore essere qui veramente adesso
ricordato un po mia cugina
ok rossa adesso sta bene ha 23 anni e
tra sette mesi diventerà mamma
sono davvero davvero orgoglioso di lei
vorrei concludere il tutto dicendo una
cosa a voi presenti qui che essere un
medico non significa soltanto praticare
la medicina della sua forma cioè nel
senso non bisogna seguire le linee guida
alla perfezione ma bisogna essere
comunque delle persone innanzitutto non
the robot esseri umani io penso che per
essere dei bravi medici bisogna
soprattutto capire cosa significa
soffrire per un paziente
io fidatevi sono stato due mesi in
ospedale quasi e so cosa significa stare
male subire un intervento è quello che
c'è dopo anche quindi quello che voglio
fare io è essere un grande medico un
bravo medico per la gente soprattutto
una persona molto umana
grazie
[Applauso]